welcome back to las vegas now millions
of people live
every day with severe pain it doesn't
matter if you start hurting today or if
you're dealing with an injury from 30
years ago
dr devin at spinal care of nevada and
his gentle method of chiropractic care
can help
[Music]
when my back gets out of alignment it
pinches nerves
and nerve pain is pretty awful you
are just mentally exhausted from
this pain that just seems to go
like this all day long
and at times i cry sometimes it's a
lifetime of wear and tear we have old
accidents false injuries we think
nothing about but they catch up to us
down the road i came in and i was
literally hobbling in the door
you know i was bent over i couldn't even
stand up straight my wife faye
oh it's been probably now eight months
ago she started developing
uh tiredness fatigue uh she had
headaches she had nausea
started getting some adjustments and
probably after about three four weeks
she started feeling a little bit better
noticeably so and in about two months
magically so to speak she was fine
tunuca chiropractic
is a more gentle style of chiropractic
the the gentle approach avoids the the
twisting the cracking
or the manipulation um and our patients
just prefer that
we can treat a wide range of patients uh
young children
um people who've been in bad car
accidents bad falls maybe we've even had
surgery before
up to 80 90 year old men and women with
severe osteoporosis and arthritis so
really one of the keys to our success
is our two day work up day one we're
going to sit down
and i'm going to listen to our patients
and i mean truly listen we'll run a
series of tests checking every range of
motion of their spine orthopedic
neurological test posture
and then we're going to take digital
opposing view x-rays these are some of
the best
type of films in our field i'm going to
study those i'm going to study the notes
so day two we're going to sit down and
i'm going to go over the findings and
listen if i can't help someone i'm going
to let them know and i'm going to get
them to the right doc if i can help
i'm very straightforward how long is it
going to take what's it going to cost
what's my insurance do or not do
because if you're anything like me you
don't want financial surprises and we're
going to get to work
and start getting some relief as soon as
possible my life's changed immensely
i'm pain-free where i used to have
shoulder neck pain i wasn't able to lift
my arms
brush my own hair it's almost like a
relief
when he adjusts i can feel it
like that it's it's it's amazing
normally that two-day work up is 180
what we're going to do for viewers of
the show is give it to the first
20 callers i have to limit it after that
it goes up to regular price for only 37
you heard dr devin the first 20 callers
will only pay 37
for both normally it's 180
call 702 566 hope
or 4673 you can also get more
information at drdevin.com